لتحقيق التعاون الايجابي المنشود بين
الدول ووفقا لمبادئ القانون الدولي وحسن
الجوار وعدم التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه
واحترام السياده الوطنيه للدول لما يحقق
المصالح والمنافع المشتركه ويساهم في
تحقيق الامن والاستقرار للمنطقه وللعالم
ونود ان يؤكد على تضامني سلطنه عمان مع
جمهوريه العراق
ودعمنا ومساندتنا للحكومه العراقيه لتحقيق
تطلعات الشعب العراقي الشقيق في الرخاء
وفي الامن والازدهار
مقدريننا كافه الجهود التي تبذل
للتوصلي الى ارضيه مشتركه اقليميه ودوليا
لتعزيز الشراكات بين الدول والتبني الحوار
البناء الذي يحقق المصالح المشتركه للجميع
ويعززي ويعزز الجهود لتحقيق التنميه
الاقتصاديه المستدامه
كما نؤكد على دعم سلطنه عمان
لكافه الجهود للتعامل مع التحديات الناجمه
عن التغيير المناخي
معربين عن تهانينا لفخامه الرئيس عبد
الفتاح السيسي رئيس جمهوريه مصر العربيه
الشقيقه للنجاح الذي حققه مؤتمر المناخ
بانتسبا في شرم الشيخ
وتطلعنا للمشاركه الفاعله في المؤتمر
القادم
الذي ستستضيفه دوله الامارات العربيه
المتحده الشقيقه والخروج بمزيد من النتائج
الايجابيه الداعمه لجهود مكافحه التغيير
المناخي والوصول الى الحياد الصفري
الكربوني
والانتقال التدريجي للطاقه النظيفه
والمتجدده حيث وضعت بلادي
استراتيجيه وطنيه في هذا الشان للشراكه مع
المجتمع المحلي والدولي ومؤسسات المجتمع
المدني والقطاع الخاص
وانشات لجنه وطنيه للتغير المناخي تنفذ من
خلالها خطط التكيف والتخفيف من اثار
التقلبات المناخيه والعمل على تحقيق
الحياد الصفري الخالي من انبعاثات الكربون
بحلول العام 20 50 وفي الختام يسرني ان
اعرب عن بالغ الشكر والتقدير للمملكه
الاردنيه الهاشميه الشقيقه حكومه وشعبا
على حفاوه الاستقبال وكرم الضيافه الاردني
الاصيله متمنيا لكم جميعا دوام التوفيق
والصحه والسعاده والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[تصفيق]